Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
I will not fear for you are with me. You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning,
I went to sleep with gum in my mouth and now there's gum in my hair.
And when I got outta bed this morning,
I tripped on the skateboard and I can tell it was going to be a terrible,
horrible, no good, very bad day.
There were lima beans for dinner. I hate lima beans.
There was kissing on tv. I hate kissing.
My bath was too hot. I got soap in my eyes.
My marble went down the drain.
The Mickey Mouse nightlight burned out and I bit
my tongue. It has been a terrible,
horrible, no good, very bad day.
Now, if you know your great literature,
you recognize Alexandra in the horrible, no good, very bad day.
My wife is an elementary teacher and she helped me prepare for this and get
this, get that ready.
I just want you to know that the horrible, no good,
very bad day is a very AP description of Psalm
55. And that's where we are this morning. Uh,
we've had some really fabulous messages up to this point. And,
and after me follow the Psalms, it'll be 56 next and on down.
But I get chapter 55 of, of Psalm, uh, Psalm 55. And uh,
just turn there with me if you would.
And this little poem is an AP description of Psalm 55
because Psalm 55 is just not much fun.
It's a, uh, psalm where David takes off and,
and you see that there's some psalms that are fun. You know, the 23rd Psalm,
the Lord is my shepherd.
I shall not want Psalm 100 make a joyful noise under the Lord.
All he lands come before his presence with singing. Those are fun Psalms.
Those are beautiful psalms. Those are Psalms you memorize.
I don't know anybody in the world who's ever memorized Psalm 55.
Uh, it's just hard. Psalm 55 deals with a lot of emotion.
And this morning we're going to take a look at that and see these emotions.
David is so concerned about this psalm when he starts it,
he uses very emotional words. And he says to God,
give ear a tend to enter me.
Listen to me. And when he addresses God,
he addresses God as Elohim.
Elohim is the name for God as mighty creator.
David is looking for a powerful God.
He's looking for a God who gets things done and that's who he addresses.
And so David is distracted
by a noisy world. We're gonna see that he's distracted by a noisy world.
We're gonna look at verses one through 15 of Psalm 55.
Give ear to my prayer of God and hide not yourself from my
plea for mercy. Attend to me and answer me.
I am restless in my complaint.
And I moan because of the noise of the enemy,
because of the oppression of the wicked. For they drop trouble upon me.
And in anger, they bear grudge against me.
My heart is in anguish within me.
The the terrors of death have fallen upon me.
Fear and tremblings come upon me and horror overwhelms me.
And I say, oh, that I had wings like a dove. I would fly away and be at rest.
Yes, I would wander far away. I would lodge in the wilderness.
I would hurry to find a shelter from the raging wind in tempest,
destroy. Oh Lord,
divide their tongues for I see violence and strife in the city.
Day and night, they go rounded on its walls and iniquity and trouble are within.
It ruined in its midst.
Oppression and fraud do not depart from its marketplace.
For it is not an enemy who tuns me that I could then I could bear it.
It is not an adversary who deals instantly with me, then I can hide from him.
But it is you, a man, my equal,
my companion, my familiar friend.
We used to take sweet council together within God's house.
We walked in the throng, let death steal over them,
let them go down to shield alive for evil is in their dwelling place
and in their heart,
David is distracted by a very noisy world.
Now, this, this, this psalm of David does not have dates.
It doesn't tell specific places,
events even doesn't even tell who the friend who was that betrayed him.
And there's a reason at the very beginning, David says,
he says, in to the choir, master with stringed instruments,
a mask of David.
Now a mask is a teaching song.
This is Psalm 55 is a musical. It's what it is.
It's a musical. It was written with stringed instruments in mind.
We don't have the score of the music, but we have the manuscript,
we have the singing for the, the word part of the singing.
And we don't know what the, we don't know what the music sounded like.
And it was probably a chant with string instruments. We don't know. We,
we don't know what it was. But it is a musical as a mask.
It's a musical for teaching.
And that is what David seeks to do with this song.
So when he sang this inside of, of their,
their center for that,
people were listening and they were learning what David had to say.
Now this is real, but David wants to make this lesson.
So David beg,
his song begins as a cacophony.
That's a real fancy word for noise. It is a cacophony,
it's a discordant mixture of sounds,
dissonance and harshness.
It's like the six o'clock news. That's what it's like.
Am I not working? Yo, y'all can hear me.
Can't you hear me? More or less? All right, well that is better.
Thank you. That's the boss, by the way. So, hi,
this is noise. It's what it is. A cacophony is just noise. It's,
it's discordant.
And so David is telling a story with this music.
He's having problems. So David gives his complaint.
Here's the complaint that David gave. This is David's complaint.
In verses three, nine and 11, there was noise, oppression, trouble,
anger, grudge, violence, strife, iniquity, fraud, ruin, war.
All of these things were going on in this song.
And so this was David's complaint.
His emotions were, he was restless. There was anguish,
terror, fear, trembling, horror,
oppression. All of these were the feelings.
These were the emotions that he had about what was going on in this,
in this psalm. And then here was his reaction. I like his reaction. He said,
I want to fly away. I want to wander far away.
I want to lodge in the wilderness and I want to find a
shelter to hide. Now
this psalm is difficult and it talks about
bad things. And it was written 3000 years ago.
It's 3000 years old. And folks, I, in looking at this and reading,
this is the first time I've ever preached Psalm 55. But in studying this,
I came to realize at Psalm 55, those 3000 years old,
it is more appropriate to our lives today
than it may have been in the days of David,
because we live in a world full of noise.
We live in a world of discord, of dissonance and harshness.
It's just everywhere. And so here's, here's what he does. He,
he says, we live in this and this is difficult. Now we have,
we have schedules, we have calendars, we have lists, we have tasks,
we have bills, we have decisions, we have interruptions, we have attacks,
betrayal, criticism, crisis, fear.
And that's just the short list of what we have in our lives.
We live in a mean world. We live in a world of anger,
hateful words and actions. And it comes to the point where we say to God,
God, Lord, sovereign,
would you please deliver us from all this
noise and all these issues? You know, I'm a,
I pastored for 40 years and then I retired and my wife and
I moved to Edmonds so I could be with my kids and mainly my grandkids.
But we came here to live and this is what we wanted to do. I was here for just,
I was retired for about three months and I became a hospice chaplain.
And I've been a hospice chaplain for three years.
And we had a meeting the other day and one of our hospice nurses was sitting
beside me. And, and, uh, she is a sweetheart. She is a great nurse,
compassionate, kind, always gentle,
always fun to be around and just the neatest lady in the world.
And we got up and was getting ready to leave. And I said, well,
how are you doing?
And it was more of just a kind of a generous little tip, my hat to you.
You know what she told me?
And she told me and she told me, and she told me.
And she lined out an entire litany of
crisis, of hurt, of anger, of,
of just disloyalty.
And I was just taken back by this girl who
smiles and everything is great. And about that,
deep underneath all that kindness and gentleness was just the biggest
hurt in the world. Now
that describes all of us at one point or another,
and maybe just right now in your life,
and this is important for us to understand what David has to say.
Dr. Thomas, a few weeks ago, he said this in a sermon. He said,
you have a God who sees you, who knows you, who loves you,
sees you, knows you and loves you. And that's important for us to understand.
And that's what David wants us to see.
And so he describes in graphic detail about being distracted by a noisy
world. Then he says, I want you to be attentive to the word of God.
And this is where we kind of get some good news in all of these issues. See,
we have someone who hates us. Satan hates us. He wants to destroy us.
He wants to hurt us. He wants to damage us as best he can. But God loves us.
He knows all about us. He cares about us, and he loves us. So we're gonna be,
he wants this to be attentive to the word of God.
And so I wanna read verses 16 through 23 and
see what David has to say. Now he's,
he had this whole lineup of bad things up to verse 15.
And then he says,
but I called to God and the Lord will save me evening
and morning. And at noon I utter my complaint and I moan.
And he hears my voice.
He redeems my soul and safety for the battle that I wage for.
Many are arrayed against me. God will give ear and humble them.
He who is thrown from old say law because they do not change and do not
fear God. My companion stretched out his hand against his friends.
He violated his covenant. His speech was smooth as butter.
Yet war was in his heart. His words were softer than oil,
yet they were drawn swords,
cast your burden on the Lord and he will sustain you.
He will never permit the righteous to be moved but you,
God will cast them down into the pit of destruction.
Men of blood and Tre shall not live half their days.
But I will trust you. Now, folks,
this this is the good news.
This is where we come and just look before God and say, God, you're there.
You're, you're God. I call the God. He says, and I'll, the Lord will say me.
He hears my voice. There is where we need to be.
Now here's the problem.
We perceive certain things that are real,
but we perceive them in certain ways that they're concrete.
When God all along has completely different truths for us to understand and
to know. And this is real important,
there's a story of Elisha Elisha in, in second King, six.
Elisha was a prophet of God. He was very well known, he's very powerful.
And he was protecting his king from being attacked by the king of Syria.
And the king of Syria found out about it and said, I'm gonna kill Elisha.
So the king of Syria puts together an army and he comes to
where Elisha lives. And there his army is a raid,
ready to do battle for one reason, to assassinate Elisha. Well,
elisha's servant got up in the morning to do whats whatever servants do in the
morning. And when he did, he saw the army of the, of the king of Syria.
And it was massive. And the the observant came back in and yelled, Eli Elisha,
Elisha, an entire army is here to assassinate you.
He Elisha looked at the servant and says, listen,
there are more who are for us than those
who are for them. And then the king or the Elisha said, Lord,
if you would please open my servant's eyes.
And the servant looked and it says that the mountains were arrayed
with the horses and chariots of fire of God
to overwhelm the king of Syria. Now,
that's the one thing the servant saw what was real,
but it really wasn't real because God is God and he had an entire
army to protect Elisha.
We need to learn when those things and those times come when we can trust God
and know what he is and who he is. But you see, God is Lord,
he's master, he's creator. He's the God most high.
He's a shepherd. He's a provider. He's the rock.
Our refuge, he's a healer, a banner under which we serve.
He's faithful. He's just, he's glorious, he's holy, he's loving,
he's wise, he's merciful, he's gracious.
God is enormous.
God is powerful. God knows all things,
sees all things he loves in a perfect manner. Every one of us,
you see our problems and fears become smaller as
our understanding and our knowledge and our experiences of God get
bigger. When we grow in our faith with God,
our problems just begin to dwindle away if we trust God.
Now, David's musical, his his,
this song went on to say in verse 22,
cast your burden on the Lord and he will sustain
you. Now,
I want to kind of explain this because it is so fabulous of a phrase.
This psalmist is hard. And then you get down to verse 22.
And this verse is worth gold. You know what the word cast, it says,
cast your burden to God. Now,
when I started looking at that and realized what the definition of that was,
the only thing, the way, only way I could describe it was as a teenager,
when I had to go out and help my uncle in the, in the,
in the fields and to feed cattle, he would make me load the truck.
And so I would have to go get these 50 pound bags of,
of cattle cake of of feed and I would put 'em on my shoulder and I would carry
'em to the truck.
And then I would roll them off my shoulder into the truck.
You know what that rolling, that rolling that load off is,
it's the word to cast,
to cast my burden is to roll something off
into the hands of God. Now when you hear the word sustain,
when you roll it off into the hands of God,
God holds that problem in his hands.
That's the word. Sustain.
I cast off my burden and God then
carries it in his hands.
Now,
there is no more beautiful picture of what we can do with God and say to him,
Lord, here is my problem.
Here are my issues and I give them to you.
Well, this is where we grow in our faith.
When we start casting off our problems that beset us and weigh us down
and keep us from serving him. And we trust him to take care of those issues.
He loves us.
He wants to carry our burden as he carried the cross.
Now, I want to, I just wanna share as a, as a hospice chaplain,
I have people that I see and some of them you really are really neat
in how they live.
I have a gentleman that I see who is without a doubt the most brilliant
man I've ever met. The man has a PhD in music. He is,
he is just the sweetest spirited man. He, he,
uh, was a professor. He was a master musician,
a concert pianist. He practiced twice a day.
He has a disease and he's under hospice care.
And now he spends his day laying in bed and he's,
he's really funny to see him cuz he just sits ram rods straight in bed asleep.
And the way he'll sit there, and when I go by to see him,
I'll wake him up and we visit. He eats a great effort.
He speaks with great effort. In fact, when he speaks,
I have to take a chair up and I'll set a chair right beside his bed and lean
over close to him so I can hear what he says. Now,
our world defines us many times by what we look
like or what's happening to us or by our, our handicaps or our our issues.
And you would look at this man and say, well,
he is defined by the fact that he can't do any of these things any longer.
And so that's what he is.
And I want you to understand that this gentleman has never
ever said anything about his disease in his limitations in his life.
When I come to visit him, I pull the chair up beside him and we talk about God.
He quotes psalms to me.
We talk about music and what is the greatest classical works of God
in music. We talk about the Bible, we talk about our lives.
He talks about his family. He wants to know about my family.
He knows every one of them. Now, he is not defined by his disease.
He's defined by his love of God.
He has never once spoken about his limitations,
only what God is doing in his life.
And he is the greatest blessing that I have during the week when I visit
my patients because he loves God and he's not limited
and he doesn't say that he, he has problems. He knows that he,
that God is foreign. You know,
this is where we come to a place to understand that
God loves us and every one of us have problems.
Everyone of us have difficulties and God wants us to bring those to him.
And sometimes we get this perception about ourselves and
what we can or can't do.
We get a perception of what's going on and we get worried about things.
It says in Psalm 46, God is our refuge and strength.
He's a very present help in trouble.
Therefore we will not fear though the earth gives way though the mountains be
moved into the heart of the sea, though it's waters roar and foam,
though the mountains tremble at its swelling.
God is there and he loves us.
We just need to kind of get out of our own way. At times,
when I was a little boy,
I went to the Clay county fair with my uncle,
the one that made me the slave of feeding the, feeding the pickup.
I went as a little boy to the, to the county fair in Clay County, Henrietta,
Texas. And I was there,
a little boy and I was with my uncle and I got lost.
My uncle left me and he left me as a little boy.
And I was standing there looking around and my uncle had left.
And all I knew what to do was to run. And so I ran, began to cry,
began to call his name. And I ran and I ran and I ran.
I ran around this massive building several times trying to find my uncle.
And I ran and I was scared and I was alone. And he had left me.
And it was pathetic
when all of a sudden this big old hand reached out and grabbed me by the
collar and stopped me and pulled me right there.
Now that was my perception that the whole world was trying to hurt me and that
my uncle had left me and that I was alone. That was my perception.
You know what the reality was? Well, here's the reality.
My uncle was standing beside me when I got lost.
He never moved. He never went anywhere.
He was standing there watching me run around this little bitty barn. And it was,
the wall was only that tall.
He could see me all the way around that barn as I ran.
And I didn't run five or six or seven times, I ran twice around a little barn.
And when I ran by, finally the second time,
he reached his hand out and grabbed me and he says, stop.
And then he said this. He said, now listen, learn this lesson.
I've never forgotten it. I've passed it on to my kids and grandkids.
If you ever get lost, if you ever get lost,
stand still.
Because someone who loves you is gonna come looking
for you. And if you're running around,
they won't be able to catch you won't be able to find you stand still.
Someone who loves you is gonna come find you.
When we're in trouble, when we're really bothered,
we need to stand still and trust God cuz he loves us.
He wants to be there for us. He wants to just help us.
Now here's what we do. This is our response. You know, David said, I wanna run,
I wanna flee, I wanna hide. I just wanna be somewhere else.
Well, we can't do that. David couldn't do that.
And that wasn't the point he was trying to make. He said,
cast your cares on the the Lord and he will carry you. So what we do,
well, you take that word, I will tru those words. I will trust you and then you.
So what you do is you tell God. You tell God, here's my concern.
Here is what's distracting me. This is what? What is bothering me.
So you tell God,
then you ask God to take you in his hand to sustain
you.
And then you honor God by expressing your faith to the
Lord and you trust him.
All of us have stress,
all of us have issues.
And David's whole musical of Psalm 55 is this,
God is infinitely interested in the
things that you face, the problems, the issues, your anger.
He knows all the emotions and he cares if you just
simply cast your cares into his hand so that
he can carry them instead of you. That's his desire.
That's what he wants for you to do. Father,
we worship you. We.